Mozza RIA makes their pizza the
old-fashioned way beautiful sauce fresh
ingredients a wood-fired oven but the
San Francisco restaurant depends on a
whole lot of slick new technology to
survive
you see missouria is 100% deaf owned and
operated i'm definitely blessed to live
in a technological world like many
restaurants Mozza RIA uses online
ordering and half a dozen delivery apps
but the pizzeria can now accept phone
calls thanks to a remarkable technology
the video relay service from the company
called canto the customer actually
speaks through an interpreter who signs
in real-time to the staff on an iPad in
the past
deaf people relied on email fax or
something called a teletype writer also
known as a TTY to communicate from the
father back when I was growing up we had
a TTY the relay service but it was
incredibly slow and so both hearing
people and deaf people just didn't have
the patience with new video relay
services the Deaf and hearing can
communicate like never before and get
this you made it all possible a small
charge on your phone bill each month
ghostly federal fund that finances convo
and other providers of video relay
services the competition among these
companies is actually quite fierce so
convo has set out to distinguish itself
with a deaf first design approach convo
came in and seeing that this was a
restaurant operating at full extent we
didn't want to put in an accessibility
machine where it's a big clunky machine
in the restaurant they have their
identity their look their aura their
moved and we wanted to see convo be a
part of that but that all started with
the lights
someone is calling you can see the light
is green and this is how our phone rings
hi there this is melody how can I help
you the video relay service is often so
seamless that customers don't realize
that the restaurant is deaf operated
until they actually come in seven
o'clock let me check
both please sometimes the hostess will
ask if they have a reservation and
they'll say yes I just called and then
they misunderstand and they say I just
called so they say their name for the
reservation and they say how do you talk
to us on the phone if you're deaf and we
explain the video relay service it's
really cool and it's also a surprise
that seamlessness and the clever design
of services like convo have been
absolutely huge for deaf owned
businesses in the past we missed about
50% of our calls
now with convo we've reduced missed
calls from 50% to only 5% there's just
one tiny problem with all this new
technology I figure we have about 11 I'm
not kidding you 11 tablets right now
imagine when it comes to charging every
night so we don't run out during
business if we could invent something
that didn't run out of batteries I would
be so much happier